hey Eric Voss here with a new Rockstar's
hot take about Avatar the way of water
the big question coming out of the movie
centered around Kiri the teenage adopted
daughter of the mysteriously impregnated
Avatar of the late Dr Grace Augustine
who was the father well based on Kyrie's
kitchen with AWA it sounds like there
was no father was really a Divine
Immaculate Conception but what is AWOL
why is AWA well James Cameron got the
name A1 from Yahweh the Hebrew name for
God and in this movie unobtanium has
been replaced with emrita that whale
brain fluid that stops human aging and
Marita is a Sanskrit word meaning nectar
of immortality I think Cameron casts
Sigourney Weaver to play Carrie because
she's gonna grow up to become the
matriarch of an avatar hybrid race whose
descendants will evolve into a Godly
hive mind that can transcend time and
loop back to give their ancestors
messages about how to stop Humanity from
stunting their evolution into a toxic
consumption self-destructive Force so
Kiri is both the child of AWA and the
mother of AWA